good evening everybody
welcome to West area planning my name is
Mark Cargill I'm chairing the meeting
this evening
lots of representation this evening so
many items right post Housekeeping's no
alarm fire alarms are scheduled this
evening so if you do hear an alarm
please make your way out and congregate
in the carpark opposite by the pub
please note this is a planning meeting
with public participation of the public
meeting only persons registered to speak
will be allowed to do so this meeting is
being webcast if you don't wish to be
shown on the big wide world web then
please let them officer know the
appropriate time for speakers this
evening tips on the microphone don't get
too close to it otherwise becomes
distorted so it's not away from a little
bit I think to talk clearly the sequence
of events for each applications as
follows I introduce the item supported
by the case officer who offers a
description town or parish councils will
be allowed to speak for 2-3 minutes
members of public objecting will be
allowed to speak for up to three minutes
the applicant for them be allowed to
speak for commercial time either three
or six minutes I will give a approximate
30-second warning for time up ward
members will then be allowed to speak
for five minutes at all stages the
member of the committee allowed to ask
questions appalling presentation we then
ask the case officer on technical
questions and then move to debate and
the vote all this is detailed in agenda
and it may ask you to turn your phone's
off or to silent please for the duration
of the meeting right there is a late a
lot they cheat for late breaking items
on your chairs right I would like now on
offices to introduce themselves starting
from my right and bands from committee
services Ross chambers legal services
Karen Tate team leader if I think
terrify my role is to act as an
impartial advisor to the committee and
with the case officer help answer any
questions which arise unbound by the
code of Professional con
of the royal town plumbing institute and
during the course of the meeting i may
seek to understand and Tesla is being
expressed by committee members this is
done to ensure that the final decision
made by the committee is best placed
withstand any subsequent challenge
committee members can balance the
planning issues as they consider
appropriate and they are not bound by
the case officers recommendation in the
agenda or by verbal advice provided this
evening thank you I'm Victoria shadow a
senior planning officer Ellen about the
planning officer thank you now to start
the meeting apologies for absence
chairman apologies from councillor Giles
for whom councillor fielding is
substituting and counts on a courage
Thank You dicks sorry did you say
disclosure of interest yes Thank You
chair did I miss the expressions of
interest no I just don't I have one I'm
the board member for an application
number 1700 74 I have formed an opinion
on this so I won't take part in a debate
if there is any as I note that there's
nobody here this evening thank you very
much indeed Cancer Council balance thank
you very much
minutes of meeting our members happy
with for me to sign the minutes after
this after the meeting thank you I shall
do so then right let's move straight
into the agenda then for this evening
the first item is application 1707 to
force rush out to school filled cottages
start from 11th and wine and that
Victoria is presenting
this light is at to school Hill cottages
on Stratford Road wooden ruin as
indicated by the black dot the site
falls within the defined built-up area
of autumn ruin and is within the West
Midlands Greenbelt the application site
includes the existing property and the
garden area of to school Hill cottages
the application has been submitted in
outline and seeks to subdivide the
existing site into two l-shape plots
attaining a reduced garden area for the
existing property and creating a new
plot for the proposed ruling as
indicated in the hatching on this plan
for your information an outline consent
has recently been approved to the plot
to the south of the site this was
approved in September of last year this
is a street view of the site showing the
existing property which fronts on to
Stratford Road this is an indicative
plan of the proposed dwelling and this
is an indicative layout plan both are
indicative and did not form part of the
proposal as it has been submitted
entirely an outline with all matters
reserved this is a view across the rear
guarding of the site towards a Stratford
Road and shows the majority of the
proposed area that would be for proposed
new dwelling this is a photo
towards the rear boundary of the site on
the left hand side is a workshop garage
and to the right is just a shed both of
which would be removed in order to allow
the development of the proposed dwelling
and finally this is an aerial shot of
the site tour Google image the red line
is my own indicative layer of how the
site would be subdivided the purpose of
the slide is to show how properties are
laid out on the Stratford Road within
their existing blocks
and the character of those plots in this
area the office of recommendation is for
refusal Thank You chair
thank you we have no speakers this
evening and I believe also a house of
Mortimer's indicated he's not speaking
this particular point can I move to
technical questions for the officer
please counsel bonds I mean the rapid
Road remain lays the Birmingham Road one
way and strap with the other yeah oh
it's a 3/4 or any other do we take it
that it's rather more back land
development than front road frontage
development I think just due to the
constraints in the site the only
possible sighting would be towards the
rear of the existing house so yes it
would be to the back of it no the
questions I open up for debate
characters Thank You chair um my
understanding is there's no such thing
as Buckland development policies anymore
I think the officer has outlines the
reasons for refusal perfectly well and
I'm entirely happy with them I recommend
I would like to push that we go with the
officer recommendation thank you do I
have a second to fill this kelsa balance
the Parish Council who supported it the
reason you haven't come to speak thank
you yes I do support that view that
they're all know if they bring it to
Council committee then they should come
on I agree with that as well
okay I have a proposer and I have a
seconder the vote tight no sorry I
already have a second to thank you
members the vote before you is 17
double-oh-seven to force rush out and
it's to refuse all those in flavor
unanimous chairman thank you this can be
therefore resolves to refuse planning
permission for 70s double-oh-seven - for
/ out thank you
the next item on the agenda is 17 sash
oh 3 6 9 1 / 4 6 Eaton Road and Victoria
is presenting again thank you
the application site is at six Eaton
Road stratford-on-avon as indicated by
the black dot the redline outline shows
the existing property and associated
curtilage in the context of the
surrounding area this slide shows the
existing front elevation of the
application site and within the context
of the surrounding area this slide shows
the existing house in elevation format
on the proposed extension the proposal
is for a first-floor side extension
above the existing garage and a
two-story and single-story rear
extension which I'll show you in a later
slide the design of the proposed
extension has taken into account a
similar extension that exists within the
existing Street shown on this side this
is a view of the existing rear of the
property in the context of its two
neighboring dwellings this is the
proposal towards the rear of the site
showing the rear two-story extension a
single-story extension and this is the
footprint at the proposed extension just
to be noted that there has been an
amendment during the course of the
application to bring back the
single-story rear element in line with
number 8 Eaton Road
there is one update on this application
and that is that since the application
since the report was written and that
the Town Council have confirmed that
they have no representations to make and
the recommendation is for approval
thank you Jim committee is that it's
them an employee thank you
we have no speakers on this item any
technical questions you would like to
ask the officer - we wish to go to Beit
council Rich's
place we go with office recommendation
here on the proposer and the second
earth remembers the boat before used to
grant plane permission to seventeen such
a through six million 1/4 though those
in favor thank you thank you this
committee therefore resolves to grant
contribution and permission for 1700
three six nine 1/4 thank you we'll just
change over presenting officers
right the next item then is 70 such oh
three two four four slash fall Aloha is
presenting Thank You chairman this
application is a full planning
application for the erection of two
detached dwellings and associated garage
in the application site lies to the
north east of the village of Clifford
chambers identified by the black dot on
the plan the site is located at the
northern end of the close adjacent to
the dwelling known as will a mayor a
public footpath runs along the access
road following along the eastern edge of
the site and then turning westwards
along the river to the north of the site
this is shown dotted green on the plan
the River Stour is located to the north
of the site with the northern corner
lying in flood zones 2 & 3 in addition
the boundary of the conservation area is
outlined in pink on the plan set some
hundred meters away from the proposed
dwellings here we have an aerial view of
the application site which is roughly
outlined in red members will note the
existing dwelling known as willowmere
adjacent to the application site and
also the paddock area within the eastern
part of the application site here we
have the proposed site plan which shows
two detached dwellings plot 1 and port 2
and their associated detached garages
and access Drive this plan shows the
elevations of plot 1 which would be a
4-bedroom detached house with a detached
double garage and garden store these are
the elevations of the dwelling proposed
at plot 2 again this is a 4-bedroom
detached house with a separate garage
and garden store we now have some photos
of the site here we're standing on the
main road that runs through Clifford
chambers looking northwards up the close
we're now standing at the end of the
close with willowmere to the left of the
photo and the application site
front of us access through the gates
gates owl attend a neighboring dwelling
is just to the right of the photo
looking directly into the applications
light onto paddock lands this would be
the access drive and plot one would be
on this pass or parcel of land directly
in front of us plot two would be located
to the left behind the trees and
existing growling the fence to the right
of the photo delineates the public
footpath that follows the perimeter of
the application site we're now stood on
the public footpath to the north of the
site looking across the paddock land
with willow mayor in the background plot
one would be located in front of us
this is standing within the garden of
willowmere looking at the existing
tennis court and outbuildings
these will be demolished and plot who
will be cited in this area again we're
still standing in the garden of
willowmere and the outbuilding to the
left will be demolished the garage in
four plots here would be located
directly in front of us and plot one
would be in in the background I now have
a video to show
and just start again
so we're standing on the public footpath
and panning around from Willie Mayer
across the paddock land where plot one
would be located and its associated
garden towards the rear of the site with
the river adjacent to the application
site there are no updates to the
application chairman the recommendation
is to refuse the application for the
reason set out on page 47 of the agenda
thank you
our first speaker this evening is
councillor there's mostly counsel you
have three minutes in that first year of
my tenure I've lived in the village for
35 years
and therefore from that I've heard some
background knowledge of this site I also
I'm chairman of currently chairman and
will be until it's completed the
neighbourhood plan development group
that has some bearing on this
application and the reason the Parish
Council is supporting you first of all
some of the history of this site the
landscape sensitivity to housing
development work that was done in 2012
actually stated that this site and
therefore from that I would take it that
the office of the time felt that this
was an appropriate area for a
small-scale development in addition to
that the parish council carried out as
part of its plan development work the
questionnaire of this year the
questionnaire care now favorably in
terms of development arm gardens and
therefore part of the reason that we
supported it was the results of that
questionnaire in addition to that in
July of this year
the parish council was consulted
from the 7th of July we should have been
consulted about the three weeks before
that but for some reason we weren't it
was fortuitous I was having the meeting
with one of your officers Matthew Neal
and he pointed out that the bullet area
boundary was different than the one that
we were proposing as part of the
neighborhood development plan we looked
at that consultation document and we
responded in the time frame that was
required and that was by the 27th of
July of this last year the plan that we
sent and the planet that was consulted
in public in two public meetings was the
one that I sent to the planning officer
when this application was first rejected
that plan will also be part of the
neighborhood plan document one is
submitted to SDC very shortly for
assessments that plan includes the form
of this garden and the reason for that
is that 30 seconds please plasma second
okay well the reason for that is that we
know that this garden has been in
existence for the best part of 25 or 30
years as a as a garden and we didn't
consider this all to be the paddock and
for that reason the parish council
strongly supporting this it's been
agreed as it were in the questionnaire
in terms of a garden developments and B
we believe it's within the built up area
boundary and it certainly will be when
we submit our documentation under the
load plant Thank You counsel
any questions members Gaza fielding how
soon before you get the neighborhood
plan coming forward the schedule of the
Mormont's is dictating that by May that
will be submitted to throughout the
district council which would be the
first line of assessments
any other questions of the counselor
okay thank you very much announcer Alex
speakers done so much so you're
struggling Donna
oh no okay
three minutes in no time and thank you
chairman I don't want to say too much
because I think most the points have
been covered by the the parish counselor
and but what I would like you all to do
is actually have a look at the plan
that's on the screen and we had this
done as we went through the application
because I think it illustrates that
putting two plots up at the top of the
clothes in no way as I have character
with the rest of the clothes or actually
the character off and Clifford chambers
I actually think it rhymes off the
clothes and in the officers report she
supports the development of plot two
which is to the left hand side as you
look at it but obviously not plot one
which she believes is mostly within
what's a paddock my my client took the
decision years ago to fence that off and
because they do have a very big plot and
but you've heard from the parish council
that you know they've quoted your own
document back at you saying that this is
a well screened piece of land which is
within that and wider settlement of the
village and I think when you look at
that plan you know as a planner I look
at that and think actually I wouldn't
know which were the two new houses that
were being proposed because it fits in
with the village so well and there isn't
a village develop a village bindery I'm
in terms of development that's being
worked through at the moment and I think
it's a balancing exercise with all
things planning that we have to look at
something and say is that out of keeping
with the care
of the village and does it cause
demonstrable harm that would warrant to
refuse off an application thank you
thank you but at the moment we are and
the office is saying that it's not
within the built-up area boundary that
is accepted has been accepted by this
council so are you saying that it is all
it's not in there or or what do you all
view on that particular elementary
please
there isn't a formal built-up area
boundary we have two plans one is the
neighbourhood plan which has done a
built-up area boundary if it's owned and
is submitted it to the council for
consideration that was done through
public consultation and two rounds of
voting happened on that plan so there is
buy-in from the villagers that the
entire redline site that you see there
is within the built-up area boundary of
the village the other built-up area
boundary which differs from the proposed
neighbourhood plan one is the one that's
formally out to consultation at the
moment and through the I can't think of
what the document is called I'm sure the
officers will be able to help but it's
basically identifying the the built-up
area boundaries around the LS fees so in
planning terms there isn't an actual
built-up area boundary and it is
therefore open to interpretation okay
thank you Tony a bit puzzled by the
comments made the Planning Officers
refers to it as part paddock Park garden
land but from what I understand from the
parish councillor they've been treating
it as garden land for the last 30 years
am i right or did I miss here no you
heard correctly this site originally was
owned by one of the lawnmower companies
and there they had quite large area
which they used to mow and test their
lawn mowers on and it's a very big piece
to look after and those fences all
across the land
and where my client has erected them
over the years just to kind of break up
that bit of land and to do different
things in different areas and but you
know it's always been part of that wider
garden and that's going back to the
1980s thank you any other questions
thank you very sure right the technical
questions you would like to ask up is
the first fall nod like to us so Oh
apologies council bonds
sorry council bars I knew you should
shut you off their apologists you
usually forget me but I'll just make to
say that the doggies voting booth this
application came in hidden the respect
some time ago the lady came to me she
said I want to build a house for my
daughter I said it's on the floodplain
oh no it's not I've been here 32 years
and it doesn't flood so I said well you
know there's a blue line I'm the
floodplain it's all on the computer
looked at it moved you back so in that
respect as far as I'm concerned they're
both in the in the correct place they're
not on the floodplain if you put on the
picture of the village could you with
the conservation area that would be
appreciated it'd be good
this is the village yeah that'll do yes
yes okay that's what the point really is
that the conservation area does take a
lot of the villager and every time we've
had an applications for people who have
has in the garden the conservation
architects opposed it so we're a bit
limited to get our 33 houses which is
the go to by the village with it all the
facilities in each house
and thereupon that's one of the reasons
that as far as I'm concerned it isn't in
the conservation area all the way along
the conservation are on that side
is in the floodplain and you can all
can't say the
down there and the River Stour we have
unfortunately or fortunately had to
build the other side of the road now
which hopefully will be in the next in
the latest their plan because in theory
we can't build actually in the village
could build on the allotments so as far
as I'm concerned this is an idea of sort
it isn't on the floodplain which it was
I understand the bit of it is a add to
the old village boundary but in as you
haven the parish council it will be in
the village boundary we are building
three houses by the pump out of the
village we've got eight hedges across
the road which are being built out of
the village because we don't really want
to I don't know what the right word is
book of the village job if you see what
I mean by having houses in it so as far
as I'm concerned the road a problem you
know it should be passed as I've just
said at the start
the dog is voting for it and he's put
his card oh thank you ask any questions
but we've got a builders going to come
along and put a lot of asses in one
place we've got a floodplain all the way
along the one village so we're stuck for
houses and this is my deal thank you
you didn't thank your motion be
councillor any questions of Castile
bonds no thank you Mary casa right now
we can move on to any technical
questions and I think the first one the
accounts for mr. Mosely meant a mention
of the housing development survey in
saying there was no problems with
small-scale development in this
particular area can you comment on that
place I think it was not aware
so do you mean the neighborhood plan
neighbor development plan isn't set yet
he was referring to a document and the
landscape sensitivity study and so the
landscape sensitivity study and it's
part of a wider document looking at
sensitivity of land and proposed
development across the wider district
that study I don't believe would have
sort of looked at specifically and the
assessment of is the site in the
physical confines or outside the
physical confines I believe it's
probably looking at more of the wider
landscape implications of built
development whether it be sort of
housing or commercial thank you could
you bring up a slight slide 23 I think
it is please might be 22 21 I was close
so just one clear is that that is the
proposed built up error boundary that is
contained within our site allocations
plan that is currently being consulted
on yes that's correct
this is the draft built up area boundary
as endorsed by cabinets that forms part
of the site allocation plan yeah okay so
there's no unless an or until that's
adopted there is no formal built up area
boundary clearly the parish council now
have an opportunity to say well actually
we don't think you've taken up enough
our neighborhood plan says this we can
then change that so it's not set in
stone yet it can be changed and I
believe yes it can be changed and that
built-up area boundaries out for
consultation and as stated by the the
parish council and the agent and the
neighborhood plan hasn't been adopted
yet that that that is still at its very
early stages
so so my only say from what I've heard
from the parish council chair that it's
the bill to bury boundary is very much a
late-stage or if not confirmed within
their documents it just hasn't been
submitted to us so my next question is
once it's submitted in your experience
how long does it take to get from the
submission through to final adoption is
it a matter of a couple of months or is
it a matter of six months or years and I
can't comment specifically on time
limits and obviously it will be a matter
of going through all the formal
consultations making sure that the plan
is sound taking it to examination and so
it wouldn't be a matter of weeks
because we're talking about six months
probably years that it's not a fair
assessment and I'd see ones list is
nodding slightly I don't know anyone
comment yeah you can't put a precise
timescale there but six months to a year
would probably be okay thank you that's
all I want to know thank you that's one
well thank you chair I think actually
council Richards asked oh one more
question I was going to and I'm very
happy with the answer thank you thank
you any other questions technical
question no I can open it up to debate
then please council fielding going on to
two precedents one is in my ward one is
where there is a built-up area boundary
and talking to John Crawford care for
the neighborhood plan will supersede the
area boundary so therefore if there is
going to be a neighborhood plan then or
as there is going to be a neighborhood
plan than they could supersede what is
up there at the moment and the second
one is a precedent in one of the
villages where we get we granted
planning permission on the grounds that
the neighborhood plan anyway was going
to be coming to the area and all we were
doing was putting off the inevitable and
I would think in this case we are
probably looking at the same sort of
problem chasm um Thank You chair yes
okay I've got a lot of simple
with the Parish Council and the ward
member my view here is that this might
come to this committee in 18 months time
when the neighborhood plan is in place
whether this proposed built up area
boundaries were accepted or not at the
moment I can't see any reason why we
could not go with the officers
recommendation and refuse this
application appears counselor of the
same wine the difficulty we've got we
don't have the benefit of the
neighborhood plan in front of us it's
not been formally adopted and therefore
we're making a decision on policies that
we have set here and the officer
recommendation has come with those
policies in mind and I think is very
appropriate given where we are now in 18
months time that may be different but we
are where we are today and I think I
would be proposing that we do refused on
that basis thank you I have to admit I
think this is a finely balanced form
because of the input from the parish
council but you're you're right it has
not come through as a formal not a
neighborhood development plan and I feel
that obviously they did come back I
don't see any reason it because the
first dwelling plot one would be
acceptable today or is acceptable today
but plot two not so I'm I agree with
castle Orton on that particular point
I'm afraid I have sympathy but I think
that we must go with the officers
recommendation and I have a proposer do
I have a seconder please thank you our
members if there's no more debate on
this particular item the other proposal
and the seconder for refusing these
claim permission this is for 17-0 three
to four for structure for all those in
favor for chairman against to chairman
okay this committee therefore resolves
to refuse planning permission for 17/3
to for 4/4 thank you very much there are
no other items on the agenda I therefore
will close the meeting thank you